le salon de l'agriculture une ferme en
plein paris qui attire les foules
des centaines de milliers de curieux
chaque année mais par le passé
l'événement est encore plus attractif il
ya des bonnes choses du banco chanson à
l'origine dès 1964 ce n'était pas
seulement un lieu dédié aux animaux et
aux produits de nos régions
l'événement se consacrer aussi aux
machines et aux outils agricoles concept
à la fois un bain de campagne par
anticipation et puis le désire également
de moderniser un appareillage un plus
ancien que nous avons pas ce que vous
avez à la gamme alliant d'une tailleuse
et puis d'une petite tronçonneuse
électrique dans les années 70 80 le
salon attire autour d'un million de
visiteurs par édition les deux tiers
venait de la campagne souvent eux mêmes
agriculteurs et ce n'est pas le folklore
qui les attirait bien traiter une
affaire de matériel
le matériel l'atout premier du salon
sauf qu'en 1991
c'en est fini le marché des machines des
ménages à villepinte en banlieue
parisienne à la même période et embarque
avec lui les agriculteurs soit
l'essentiel des visiteurs restent à
porte de versailles les animaux et les
produits régionaux ainsi que 480 mille
visiteurs deux fois moins qu'auparavant
à terme certains exposants ne voient
plus l'intérêt d'être présent à paris
mais quelques années plus tard il séduit
de nouveau sept cent mille visiteurs en
2009 et une fréquentation qui se
stabilise autour de ce chiffre dans les
années suivantes
ah oui c'est très très populaire
découverte gourmandise et folklore voilà
comment s'est renouvelé la plus grande
ferme effet maires de france
[Musique]